senior NBA writer Howard back how are
you Howard rich I'm doing alright you
I'm good I'm good family's good
everybody's good I got to be honest with
you tensions are are palpable here in
Los Angeles and I know they are in New
York City I've got a lot of friends
there as well but let's get to the
business of what happened last night
what was it just they were thinking
about doing X Y & Z and then Gobert
pops4 coronavirus and then it was all
there were no more options on the table
except one is that how it works yeah
yeah the decision was made for them rich
I mean and I don't want to be overly
critical here because this is really
really it it's it's not just a very
difficult situation but it's there's no
map for any of this there's no blueprint
you know the NBA seem to be all over the
map in recent days are they going to
play games with no fans are they going
to bow to local edicts from city
officials you know in San Francisco when
it became an outright ban like no this
is the law now that we are ordering no
gatherings and the Warriors had no
choice okay we're going to play with no
fans meanwhile the Washington Wizards
had only local DC officials saying we
don't want public gatherings but they
didn't make it the loss of the Wizards
said well well then we'll keep playing
with fans so the NBA was all over the
map and the league did not come up with
a cohesive Universal policy for all 30
teams and so in lieu of that they were
having to let team just kind of make
their own decisions based on local
situations and whether or not local
government was making it advice versus
directive and so while they're
considering all these options and what
should we do next and can we get all our
30 teams on the same page and clearly by
the reporting that's out there they were
not all in the same page and then this
happens Rudy Gobert happens it's a
positive test happens and now the
decision is made for you
because as I'm sure you've explained to
your listeners it's really simple Rudy
Gobert being positive for the virus
means you have to quarantine the entire
Jazz team and then you have to see who
they played recently and then who those
teams played recently and the referee
crews and referees crews changed night
tonight so somebody exposed to it too
Rudy Gobert one night that referee
couple nights later is good working with
a different crew now he's possibly
exposing
Becker so the cascading effect means
that you don't have a choice at that
point you have to shut down the league
and wait this thing out so I heard Mark
Cuban say that he was planning on paying
his employees that make an hourly rate
are all are all NBA teams gonna do what
Cubans doing because that is obviously
after the the I guess depression of the
situation that the NBA has got a
suspended season that's the first thing
I thought of is like what about all the
people who depend on living and making
their rent based on these home games
that aren't going to be played now I
would hope other team owners would
follow Mark Cuban's lead I would hope
that the league in fact itself would try
to rally everyone toward a policy like
that and that they would take care of
everybody who relies on this league for
their livelihoods
I've not seen or heard of any other
teams volunteering that yet doesn't mean
that they're not doing it it's still
really early and you can add that to the
list of about a thousand questions that
need to be answered hopefully sometime
soon the Board of Governors is meeting
via conference call shortly here maybe
even as we speak
right and I'm hoping that in the wake of
that we'll get more information from the
NBA about its thought process about it
what things may come next and maybe even
about things like yes how are you going
to take care of all these employees of
teams and arenas now I would ask you the
next question I will anyway and I know
the answer that nobody knows nobody
knows right I mean the this is just
basically going to take it week by week
or or or the way that we're looking at
these standings is the way that this is
going to wind up is it possible that if
everything is somehow mitigated because
this can't be you know completely
contained until there's a vaccine is it
possible that the start of next year is
delayed and this year gets finished
after a few months hiatus I mean what
what's the concept that's being
discussed right now this idea that then
the NBA would you know resume whenever
two weeks three weeks four weeks
whenever it is and reschedule all the
lost games play a complete 82 game
season start the playoffs going through
the summer I think of all the things
I've heard seems the least likely to me
because now you are you're pushing back
the drafts
free-agency pushing back or wiping out
summer league
you're probably eliminating the
possibility of NBA players playing in
Tokyo if there even is in Olympics in
Tokyo and more than any of that or at
least as important if the season doesn't
end of the finals don't end until
sometime in August I'm not sure the
players union is going to go for that
when you got to turn around and have
guys then report again a month later
that does not make much sense to me
the thing that makes the most sense to
me and to people I was texting with last
night around the league and granted none
of these people are in a position to
make the policy decision and it will be
made above their pay grade but I was
checking in with just smart people I
know around the league like what's the
most like what seems like this the most
likely scenario here and everyone's kind
of guessing but the most likely and
sensible scenario seems to be you shut
down for however many weeks this is
going to be two three even if four weeks
you wipe out what's left of the regular
season schedule you're freezing the
standings where they were last night
you play the playoffs based on those
standings and you pick up with you know
a month from now when the playoffs would
normally be starting anyway and then
you're not having to rebook arena nights
or reshuffle or do anything else and
you're not playing into the summer
you're staying on your normal calendar
and everything else is intact that seems
to me to be the cleanest way to do it
but it's easy for me to say I'm not the
one who's giving up 20-25 percent of the
season revenue is by wiping out the rest
of those games
Howard Beck a bleach report here on the
Rich Eisen show and then just the whole
idea of disruption and you know money in
the pockets of obviously the the economy
of the game outside of again the people
who depend on the wages to make ends
meet and hopefully they are made whole
by ownership and management of the NBA
it really just does pale in comparison
to public health issues so yeah what can
you what is your reporting on how it was
discovered that Gobert might have had
corona virus since he apparently was
not terribly symptomatic what happened
last night based on what you could tell
Howard I wish I had that information
rich I wish I could have more to tell
you on that I'd honestly don't know um
information on that right now is pretty
scant pretty hard to come by and and
probably for good reason
you know look there are already people
around the league who I've been in
contact with who are really upset about
the fact that Rudy Gobert and Donovan
Mitchell's names have you been put out
there at all positive because they
consider this a you know medical privacy
matter and people are sensitive about
that and I understand that and so given
that I think there's you know a lot that
has still been insulated from us and may
be properly so I you know what right do
we have to know about the players and
how they contracted it or when or
whatever I mean sure certainly everybody
they've come in contact with would want
to know that but we as the public
knowing it in though in a very you know
public way that we do know it it's it's
it's created some backlash and there are
people on the league we're concerned for
players medical privacy rights right now
and but I I don't have any insight into
how exactly this unfolded it all happens
so quickly last night where this stuff
is all still very fresh I will say this
again you know because I like having
conversations with you Howard and my
guests also as opposed to just asking
questions and hearing an answer I can
totally understand why people would say
that they're privacy's have been
breached that said the fact that their
names are associated with this virus I
think can have some greater if this
means anything to them public good that
it has shaken people awake that people
of their physical prowess and age
contracted this virus and yes they are
more likely than not to just have a flu
but they in the NBA are all over the map
literally and it's very important for us
to know who has it
and how if we can find out they got it
because it can be so
helpful to everybody everybody to
understand this and calm some nerves and
tension certainly if in two weeks from
now we find out Gobert is feeling great
right and Donovan Mitchell's feeling
great and we know that they didn't push
it around uh you know what I'm saying
out of out of everything though that I
saw by the fact that whoa just tweeting
out that jazz players are privately
saying that Gobert was careless in a
locker room now that that one like that
one's like okay that one got out now
that one was what raised kind of a
little flag and my eyebrows to go up
there Howard yeah yeah and listen rich
I'm with you like broadly speaking I
think that there is a great case to be
made for more information than less
maximum transparency and these guys are
public figures and you know I'm not
saying that means there's a public
rights to know but we do have a
tradition in this country of if you are
a public figure you give up some of your
privacy and in a case like this I do
think that that that is the the price
you pay and I don't think it's a very
large price in this case and I don't
think no one's going to train these guys
like cariah's or lepers Frank which is
what how somebody framed it to me who
was concerned about this and I said well
you know I I don't see that you know it
this is this is a virus like any other
except that right now it's a very deadly
one and a rapidly spreading one and but
everybody understands this is a
temporary thing that no one's gonna look
at Donovan Mitchell six months from now
or Rudy Gobert six months from now and
say oh you're the guy who had the corona
virus like this is not some Scarlet
Letter right so I think maybe people are
being a little hypersensitive on it but
again I get it these are people who are
advocates for the players but I I think
that it's better to know than not
especially if you were a fan who
high-fived Donovan Mitchell courtside a
couple nights ago or maybe attended some
community event with him now you know oh
wait a minute I came in contact with him
because the team can't possibly reach
out to every single person or know it
who every single person is who might
have come into contact with those
players and so if you do name them
publicly again the league isn't doing
that reporters are doing that but there
is a public good that can come from that
on a variety of levels
last one for you is it I mean whoa
saying also that the Knicks were the one
team that wanted to keep the status quo
until a governmental public mandate
dictated change that what do you think
what do you think of that one Howard I
think it reminds me of something said
once by the the late commissioner David
Stern who back during a different time
said of the Knicks that they are quote
not a model of intelligent management
and that was specific to to something
else it was that was specific to a
sexual harassment lawsuit that they
refused to settle but that statement has
echoed through the years because we can
apply it again and again and again to
how the Knicks operate and this is just
one of those things where like the
second you saw that report you thought
yeah yeah I can see it I totally that's
exactly what I expect the next to do
although and again I don't want say the
Knicks it's James Dolan yeah no I know
that's it in that's the problem
you know that's why the statement that
came out from the Knicks that broadsided
Spike Lee they should he just hid behind
the the the name and the logo he didn't
put his name on it
and it's just I find it fascinating
ironic and of course as you ported on
brand that he would say you know I need
I need to know about a public mandate
before shutting down Madison Square
Garden to protect Knicks fans and New
York City writ large certainly since
many of them take the train to come to
the game yeah but he won't acknowledge
the clear public mandate for him to sell
the damn team I find that fascinating
he's not one to listen to other people
that's just it just depends on it
depends on what the public mandate is
about I guess look I appreciate it
I appreciate the time Howard I
appreciate the conversation and I know I
just hope you and everyone you know is
Hale Hardy and well and next time we
speak I find nothing different
so thanks they call me same to you my
friend good talking to you my bestest to
you and thank you brother that's Howard
back of bleacher report